kids are always like my mom's not
putting me on my dad's not letting me do
my thing and I'm like you're entitled
you're 22 you're walking into a business
that's been alive for 15 years your mom
and dad have all these other employees
that put the bricks down to [__] make
this place and just because you won the
[__] sperm game you think you are
earn something shut the [__] up and work
for a decade attention is the number one
asset my dad doesn't listen my dad
didn't listen to a single thing I was
thinking I did [__] and when he was like
that wine isn't selling and I saw and I
sold all 19 cases miraculously my dad
started to listen the number one thing I
asked kids I'm like well what have you
done well he won't let me do anything
I'm like you are coping the [__]
out